Keanu Reeves may be best known as a
Hollywood action man but in his private
life his passion is motorcycles
welcome to arch totally custom handmade
motorbikes this is the bike that I was
like okay what can we do from here let's
start you know let's bring this to the
world he and his friend and business
partner guard Hollinger build them here
at their shop south of LA it's a mix of
old-school handcraft
and the very latest materials and tools
including virtual reality to make some
of the most custom bikes on the market
it's Joe's bike this bikes going to
Australia
the partnership started in 2007 it's
probably best to let the guys tell the
story before there was arts motorcycle
there was Reeves looking to customize a
harley-davidson
I was introduced to guard Hollinger
California designer manufacturer custom
motorcycles infamous famous
well-regarded
innovator designer God agreed to
customize a bike but then went so much
further
basically just keeping the engine and
designing everything else from scratch
it was no longer a harley-davidson was
becoming a chop rods motorcycle which
was the company that guard had and in
that process you know I had gone looking
for a kind of chopper big twin kind of
California cruiser but wanted it to
perform over the course of five years
four and a half years that motorcycle
was developed and built eventually
became the prototype for arch
motorcycles only five years it was only
five years so we went from the prototype
to the arch KRG t1 the design I mean
this exposed frame member you know the
our Channel and of course you got this
beautiful long delicious sexy welds now
the company makes the custom KRG t1 by
hand
to order every bike is totally bespoke
built for its new owner and prices start
around seventy eight thousand dollars so
this is one in process sort of in its
rarest form basically just a chassis
with the engine sitting in it some front
forks but
it's a nice view of this downdraft
induction system that we designed
building these beautiful machines have
been enough to keep the company busy and
the owners happy until now it's time for
something new the guys are working on
new bikes an update to the KRG t1 a
sportier arch 1s and a more radical
machine and the last bike is a very very
limited production very I think
forward-thinking the design piece with a
big giant engine because 124 cubic
inches wasn't enough that Mike will be
known as the arch method 143 guard and I
and everyone involved in the company
have a design ambition and and I think
it's you want to grow creatively and in
what you make Keanu and God take design
seriously they've been working with the
company VIN Tech which is just down the
road from their workshop to visualize
the bikes from every angle in virtual
reality before they're even built right
VR is one of your other tools yeah get
in there okay this is when things start
to feel a little bit Hollywood I hope
that Keanu Reeves holding my virtual
reality umbilical cord out of the way is
as close to the matrix as I ever
actually get
putting the motorcycles side-by-side so
there's an element of the KRG t1 then
looking at the 1s and then looking at
the prototype 143 and you can see them
side by side and kind of experience the
connections and relationships that go
from model to model and see the story
ultimately bikes are about riding
something that Keanu and guard never
forget and don't want their customers to
either they're not planning to grow too
dramatically they still want to make
hand-built
beautifully designed and rare motorcycle
you